So now that we have seen that unrolling can really help both reduce the overall
work, and also schedule the work better. We might be tempted to do unrolling all
the time. So is there any downside to unrolling? Well, yes there is. So
first there is code bloat.
Let's say that our original body was four instructions. After we unroll, for
example it might be that instructions one through three,. Need to be replicated,
and this is for example our branch, so we can just have one. So now there is
fewer instructions executed per original iteration. We had four per iteration,
now we have seven per two iterations. But the code size is much larger. Here we
had four instructions in a our code, now we have seven instructions in our code.
If we decide to unroll more than once, meaning. Do the work of let's say,
four of these iterations. The code size will be proportionally larger.
So the code grows quickly, with the number of un-rollings with we do. Second,
what if the number of iterations is unknown at the beginning? For example,
this could be a while loop. In that case, here, we do one iteration at a time.
Here we're doing two iterations at a time. What if we needed to exit here?
Even in a four loop where we know the number of iterations in advance.
What if the number of iterations we need is not a multiple of N?
The number of iterations we are doing per iteration of the loop. So
we might still for example, we might need to do seven iterations of this loop.
We unroll it once. Now we need to do this three times and then exit in
the middle. So, how do we handle this? The solutions to this problems do exist,
but they are beyond the scope of this class. So, these are questions that
are better answered in advanced compiler class, not in an architecture class.